moldavia y ucrania han agradecido a la
comisión europea al reconocimiento de
ser países candidatos a la unión europea
para el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski este es un gran paso para
acercar al país hacia la victoria
georgiano ha conseguido el estatus de
candidato porque antes la comisión
europea le pide que hagas reformas aún
así el país considera que es un camino
para poder acercarles a la unión europea
se trata de un apoyo moral para los
países pero sobre todo para ucrania que
pidió el estatus de candidato hizo
oficial su candidatura a tan sólo cuatro
días después de que estallara la guerra
eso sí la comisión europea lo deja muy
claro los dos países tanto moldavia como
ucrania tendrán que cumplir una serie de
condiciones como la reforma del estado
de derecho a la independencia judicial y
también la lucha contra la corrupción si
quieren mantener este estatus de
candidato porque la comisión europea
insiste en que el proceso es reversible
y que vigilará muy de cerca las reformas
de hecho a finales de este año se va a
hacer una evaluación para comprobar si
real están yendo por el buen camino tras
esta recomendación de la comisión
europea los líderes europeos tendrán que
darle el visto bueno algo que se espera
que se pueda producir en una reunión de
líderes europeos la semana que viene aún
así esto no significa que empiece ya el
proceso de negociación hacia la unión
europea es un proceso muy largo en que
no hay tiempos límite y que de hecho es
muy complejo porque hay que negociar
hasta 35 capítulos de negociación
pasando desde la educación hasta la
economía un proceso que puede tardar
muchos años incluso el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón dijo que podría
durar hasta 20 años